It's an autonomous thinking fixed battery that came from
riding.Thank you all.
Karasuma Sensei is also having a hard time.If
I was that person, I wouldn't be able to finish my tsukkomi and
would go crazy.
You're registered as a student She points her gun at you all the way from that place
But you can't fight her back
You can't harm a student
Because that's your contract as a teacher Use the
nail hard contract to your advantage
Regardless of what you do, it's fine if you take the opportunity to be a student,
right
Autonomous Thinking Fixed Battery, I
welcome you to class e
[music]
Thank you for your patience
Well, these are the three characters.  One of them is
already dead, so how do you attack?
Are you worried about housework?
But
she evolves with her own functions
Ballistics recalculation car Various corrections Self-evolution constant 4
18021 days It
's not a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit
When
I play the ball, did you go to the same dojo as the same time as I played,
did you generate qualifications at high speed?
Probability of killing with the next shot
ada Less than 1% Probability of killing with the
next shot
Less than 3%
Probability of killing before graduation
Say more than 90%